hi today uh
you don't have to have my book but if
you've got my book handy
it'll be uh good because you can refer
to it
i've said uh to the people who joined my
patreon
site and contributed to that i said i'd
go through the book
page by page but you don't have to have
the book it's just that
everything's always good to refer back
isn't it
okay so page
page 170
page 170.
you'll need a joe those of you who've
never done the job before you'll need
a joe or buy yourself a
broom handle it
i'm going to go through the basics now
it may seem boring to a lot of people
but
if you want to be a martial artist or if
you think you're a martial artist
do you act in martial artists ways
this is the big question when you go
into a restaurant
a place to eat do you always sit with
your
back to the wall so that your you can
see
the door of the restaurant
and you can view the restaurant in
general in case there's a fallout
problem this is not being paranoid
it's being a martial artist i
sit and eat quite comfortably all my
students
know and uh my partner she knows
when we're going to restaurant old tony
i'll sit there
i've been like that now for i don't know
all my aikido career because my teachers
used to say you can't switch from being
a martial artist to a human being
um without a lot of training you have to
train to be a martial artist
naturally we're a human being but we
have a lot of errors
so if you're interested in doing this
with me then i'm going to bring out some
basic basic points that
may seem boring to most people if you
want to be a
martial artist it's the finer points
that will make you
precise that will make you accurate
in many ways within yourself and the art
you're doing it
okay so anybody that's interested in the
joe
this is a sample video for some of you
and as i said on my patreon page that
i'm building
that people contribute to they'll be
full
a fuller film okay
so i'm just going to give you
information that cytosense he gave to me
he don't have senses weapons but really
when we do the weapons i always say
we're doing cytosenses weapons
because he he made far more than what
i've sensed he ever taught him
he just kept making them and making them
in my opinion there there was far too
many but
that's just in my opinion but those who
are keen
can uh can fit them in the thing with
the
weapons is uh you need you need time to
do them
okay so notice how i'm holding my my job
i'm not loose i'm not sort of like
casual
and holding it loosely i've got all my
fingers
around the jaw the joe
is in front of my foot and
in between the big toe and the second
toe
okay the big tongue the second time now
i'm looking down so please note is that
my head is looking down
at my jaw this is a very bad
human habit and if you look at
even the obama top teachers
they will ah they would do sort of
carters and siberias
and then they have they'll they'll drop
their head
like that when they put the joe okay so
they'll be
doing their suburbs and i'll put the joe
down onto her face
and i look down like that it's a very
immature thing but it's
it's got it's
in there without them knowing it because
they haven't observed themselves
so i just said she said get a ghee
a weapons and a mirror if you haven't
got a mirror
use a door or a window that reflects
back so you can see yourself
see your incorrection imperfections
okay i know where my foot is
so why do i need to look down i don't
right so the first basic thing is to
hold the joe
now to set up a mental
idea of this i'm going to
think about myself and he
told me it means my body and posture
is small so another thing sensei said
was
imagine you're hiding behind your jaw
now it's a stupid thing to say because
look at the size of me
compared with the size of the jello but
if i think i must hide behind the joke i
will make my body as small
as i can you know i won't sort of stand
like this i'll go
oh how small can i how small can i make
my body
you know without turning the feet wrong
so the angle is very important
okay so fingers
don't look down
try a few times take your joe
don't look down just place it there
if you look down at first because you
need confidence that's fine
but you know it's not a big thing don't
worry about it
but if i look down oh yes it's in
between my big toe
and my next toe it's because i've done
it so many times
so if you're going to look down don't
keep doing it
if you do a carter remem the minute you
start to put your head down
get a red light in your head to say
don't do that
sensei used to say to me i remember
being in walmart
he said don't worry tony as soon as you
go to make a mistake
with all your knowledge now you will see
a red light in your head
i know i now know what it means i didn't
at the time
okay the next point i'd like to make is
don't just pick the joe up if you pick
the joe up it's easy look it's easy to
pick up and put it in the hand
i must go to the job okay
but this is something i mustn't do see
how square i am now
how wide i am
i mustn't do this but you'll see
everybody do it
i'll either do this to get to their joe
or they'll do this to get to their job
or they might even do a half way to get
into the joe
where's the next big problem
the next big problem is
like you'll come here and they'll come
here and they'll leave a little bit out
of the jar
or when they've done a striking movement
or a skier movement
they leave a bit at the job since you
said
they could use this if somebody grabbed
your joe
in joe dory joe nagy they could use that
and do an iccia on you with your own job
so if you
don't have anything out the end
they can't do it okay
the hand the hand end
can you see here the hand end
is half on and half off the joe
not there with a little bit of joe
sticking out
not too much but
the little finger should be half on and
half off the go
this is the same when holding the ken
so you're learning two things in one
the next thing is it's good to come up
against a wall
and a lot of people they do that they go
back into the
they go back and then they go forward
with the scheme
okay so they go back and forth
sensei also used to say think that
there's a wall behind you so
i'm putting my elbow on the wall
my elbow on the wall so i'm in the
skinner come on
if i go forward with my hand
and ski
forward with my hands key i'm always
only going forward
if i go if i take back
to pump it the the time i do that
okay so the time i do that your attacker
could come in because they would see an
opening they'd see you're moving
but look i'm going the wrong way my joe
is going the wrong way isn't it
i should be going forward so here
you slide the front hand front hand
and forward bend the knees
so i'm against the wall with my
with my elbow i'm against the wall
i'm against balls i soften the knees as
i slide
i soften the knees as i slide now it's
my
torso and that doesn't move it doesn't
it doesn't go like this and then like
that
we don't want to pump it soften the
knees
slide this hand
the wrist
the wrist should
not go past my body if it's here
it's too far i'm starting to
go outside my natural center this is not
far enough
this is not far enough it's when the
wrist
is in line with your torso
so even though it seems basic there's a
lot to
work on isn't there
so i can now go against the wall
with my whole arm my
my buttocks uh my right buttocks
touching the wall
i'm hiding behind my jaw
i'm softening my knees and
notice my torso my shoulders
they're not going to come round and i'm
going to try and reach my joe
now this will take may not take you
months but it took me months and months
to learn this i have to use some yoga
or the understanding of yoga so here
i don't want this shoulder to start
coming around
so i have to find length in the arm
and i have to find softness in the body
so i get it this way
okay try it against the wall because it
really restricts
you okay so i'm hiding behind my joe
my hands are not loose but my hands are
all the fingers around it not tight you
just need to hold it
okay so i
softened my reach i take it i ski
i hide behind the jab my fingers around
my gaze is forward i mean he'd tell me
i soften i take up
i go forward half on half of
the little finger don't look down when
you put it down
okay if this was a wall obviously it's a
curtain but if it was a wall it would
it would tell me if i'm gonna
be hitting the wall or not
so you move forwards
folds
you can do all that piece by piece
and you'll be doing really well it's the
precision that makes
you good not the repetition
repetition once you get it correct and
do it like this slowly
repetition is then done well
a thousand cuts done badly
and one cut down good you know the
answer for that
the next thing is why don't why is it so
important that i don't just pick my joe
up if that's what i want
somebody's coming why don't i just pick
it up
since he also said what about someone
else has a joke
and as you're doing that they knock it
away
and as they knock it away
you can't you can't grab your joe
you know they've taken control and while
you're busy trying to get it
so he said it's on the ground
that's where you put it you go to that
it's on the ground you go to that three
i'm doing this in my bedroom you can do
it
inside if you can go outside we will be
doing a lot of work outside
and with detail but these can be done
inside
so page number 117
it tells you in there these exact same
details
but not fully it doesn't tell you about
this little finger
and these these other points look
straight ahead
fingers round
a soft body but an alert body slightly
bent
front leg not not you don't want your
legs locked
back legs just soft soft but not not
collapsed
so you and you and he told me that
something he turned me with the body
fingers around here i go to
this i and when you scare you're in
that's the chokazoo if
if you were in um
if you were in the rest position
the hand would sit back on this
the hand would sit back on this this
muscle here don't pull it back here
just be there when you go
when you do the ready position you just
bring that front hand a little bit along
as you move the front leg
okay so it's coordination of your body
so it's
you're looking forward come here
and you're ready okay
you're ready when you ski
this backhand you'll notice a lot of uh
teachers even you know the alarm
teachers i'm talking about as well
don't do this you see the back let's see
the finger here
sensi told us never do that because if
you've got a finger
sticking out it can be easily hit
and broken with another person's job so
don't do it
he always used to say just tuck it in
or don't have it out too much you'll see
a lot of teachers do this
this is a human fault this is a this is
a human aerophone
not a martial artist fault
i must admit though i used to see him
with his finger out many times
but he was telling us what we must do
his lower grades
and his eye could i was so superbly
refined
but i'm just saying he would shout at us
if we would do
this but if he done it obviously nobody
was there to tell him
check yourself every time check yourself
every time he would say each one is one
each one is one each one
is one don't bring the body round
keep it so it doesn't move
don't pick up the joe at all
keep it fixed you go to the joe
keeping the shoulder back pick it up
ski without you going back okay
you have more than enough there to work
with
we'll keep going further and we're going
to go through the book in the stages
that i that i made it because i think
then points are important
whether you do or not um i can't help
you it's just the way i was taught
okay such a sense he would teach
differently in iwan than when he used to
travel the world
because he realized that around the
world and people were not putting in the
same amount of
time as anyone you know they were there
every single day twice a day six days a
week they would train
they would have one day off mondays
um around the world now if you're a real
keen
like the harness you seem to work is
three days
so so the past is the past but the
but the exact points are to be adhered
to
please remember this thank you for your
time
oh one small point uh when you get your
bronze stick it should fit under your
armpit like this
not not sure or taller or if it doesn't
just slide under your armpit it's like a
pair of shoes it's
not the size for you thanks for your
time